dimanche 13 janvier 2010 neuf premières
journées nationales d hyper sensible de
l'histoire
en france plus de 10 millions de
personnes sont concernées nos sens sont
exacerbés
on peut être ému par plein de choses de
manière beaucoup plus forte que d'autres
on peut se sentir inadaptée aussi au
monde tel qu'il est parce que c'est
vraiment un monde assez dur qui nous
entoure et on peut sans se sentir
vraiment à part les hyper sensibles ont
souvent une grande créativité qu'ils ont
pu exprimer leurs de l'atelier 2 s'offre
aux créations proposées par
l'association cubique au ma créativité
est un outil pour passer de ce qui peut
être ressenti comme souffrant à quelque
chose qui devient justement porter voire
joyeux en tout cas qui devient une façon
de produire quelque chose avec ceux
qu'on aime
crayons feutres les participantes ont pu
laisser sortir leurs élans de créativité
renforcée par un état de relaxation
c'était une première expérience de
sophrologie j'étais curieuse de savoir
qu'est ce qu'on peut ressentir par
rapport à la création puisque je crème
et je suis assez mental donc c'est
difficile de me libérer de l'intérieur
libérer sa sensibilité autres
possibilités avec l'atelier d'écriture
pour un public de gens forcément
sensible et bien par les cris on va
pouvoir leur proposer de parler d'eux
mêmes et pour ces gens là c'est souvent
difficile
tous les ateliers se sont déroulés en
petits groupes dans une atmosphère
bienveillante la journée nationale de
l'hypersensibilité se déroulera
désormais chaque année le 13 janvier